I'm a rapper and that is I am that's how
badly brexit went
um we'll get five suggestions then we'll
drop a beat do a freestyle we'll come to
this uh this section first to kind of
like shadowy Enclave hello shadowy
Enclave what would you like a rap about
prince Andrew okay well no I mean look
look there's a fan in the front row he
loves it
loves it prince Andrew let me um now we
all know what prince Andrew uh allegedly
did I look easy still he's still partly
in charge of my country he could have me
beheaded um
let's let's put him in a let's give me
an activity that's not salacious
well no that's salacious isn't it yeah
I'm saying there's something like 10 Pin
bowling or or scuba diving grocery
shopping prince Andrew grocery shopping
thank you just just because even though
I'm in your country I'm Bound by the
laws of my own and so I do not want to
commit high treason middle middle right
hand side Steven Spielberg Steven
Spielberg and why did I make it
Spielberg that's not how his neighbors
Spielberg Spielberg uh amazing are you
what's your favorite Spielberg film Jaws
jaws that's a good choice this side of
the room people what would you like a
rap about yourself a Pachycephalosaurus
that's a that's a why did you say what
the [__] is that it's a
can you from Context from the word
Pachycephalosaurus could you guess yes
there we go the the man who looks like
Jeff Goldblum said
um that was definitely offensive I was
just like ah you look like a nerd you
look nerdy okay a Pachycephalosaurus is
that does that have like the kind of
projecting comb from the back of its
head what's it look like more of like a
helmet more of like a helmet oh kind of
like a like a Faberge eggs jutting out
or something yes yes he's just say yeah
move on Chris I'm a I'm a paleontologist
I'm not good at social interaction
what what um era was it from
it's your son's favorite dinosaur that's
very sweet that's great when you said
was I don't want to get tragic I mean
either no no I either it's no longer a
son or now he likes Raptors well we'll
hope it's that one back of the room
back of the room what would you like a
rap about
ironing straight into the point
fantastic
and thank you for a man saying that as
well because you know Jen is yeah it's a
gendered thing it's good to know that
you don't earn enough money to send your
shirts away to get them pressed by
nothing no it's fine
yeah I love it irony thank you uh over
over here you get the final suggestion
to remind you we have Pachycephalosaurus
we have ironing we have prince Andrew
doing the grocery shopping Steven
Spielberg's Jaws you have the honor the
privilege the Shrek
so red it was a week and a half ago in
here that someone someone suggested
Shrek but we've wrapped in that one
specifically about Princess Fiona having
red hair because it linked to another
topic so um pick something else from
Shrek and then we'll focus on that
the swamp all right Donald Trump fine
let's I'm gonna ask my lovely band to
produce some delightful music and we're
gonna make up a rap about all that this
is how the show ends hopefully your
suggestions were good enough to make a
good rap that's yeah this is all on you
this is all all on you not on me I
divest myself of all responsibility uh
let's have some fun
start the rap I set on the man I'm
pointing at you trying to have fun no
plan about Andrew Mr Prince even though
they take his tie all gone he's in the
aisle at Tesco why because he wants to
fill up the fridge do it a lot he no
longer got a servant for his weekly shop
looking round maybe he'll choose a bit
of custard maybe some couscous walking
up to the till saying maybe ask it do
you need help with your bagging from the
basket he says yes I'm used to being
serviced by 16 year old girls and I
prefer this a it's a pun double meaning
you were being cruel like Jeffrey
Epstein number no we switched it hip
hopping about allegedly pedophile Prince
doing that shopping then you move it on
the best in the world being observed
amazing director Steven Spielberg I'll
be loving him getting Oscar after Oscar
the fablemans yeah I know I come across
there but back in the day I was like yo
look onto the beach not a place you
would go you see the shore coming into
even throw the girl swimming on the
surface oh no she's too slow John
Williams team got the shark coming up
from under the sea you don't see the
shot to like 65 minutes in and when you
do Jesus Christ the teeth and the grin
when the little head comes to the
porthole I was like gosh it's so bloated
so swole I've got to worry about that
moving over here yeah you know I'm about
that my dude's saying yes that's a
dinosaur how do you pronounce it how'd
you spell it p-a-c-h-y I'm pretty sure
cephalosaurus like the head Packy
because they're packing it in yes it's
been said it was your son's favorite
thought it's amazing maybe you could
Jurassic Park just for Daisy Steven
Spielberg and Michael Crichton 1993 that
was the right one a tight one he also
made Schindler's List at the same time
but can you believe this what an
incredible Auto I really like over here
oh if you want to be invited to a dank
place maybe buy an ogre you say I'm
scared I don't hope to go there walk
from from the kingdom so far you've got
Shrek donkey and Lord farqua he's the
small one with the tiny little hair
turning around doing the dance he
doesn't care the swamp just for once
describe the Ooze moisture green
horrible goo he's living there Michael
Myers Eddie Murphy says my sense of
interior decoration deserts me you need
to give it a lick of new paint I'll tell
you one thing the Shrek ain't doing
taking the creases out of his smokes he
looks at all his shirts and says I've
got to stop he needs to get an ironing
thing on that so who does he ask of
course Cameron Diaz
[Applause]
foreign